welcome to hannity tonight we have
breaking news surrounding a massive
deadly explosion at a beirut lebanon
where do you see this tape
in full that's straight ahead plus we
have the very latest details from
today's
heated antifa hearing on capitol hill
senator ted cruz is with us
also condoleezza rice slamming the
thought police
on the radical left we'll explain that
also we start tonight with the
developing story out of yes
joe biden's basement bunker tonight
there are currently three
presidential debates in the works joe's
biggest fans in the media mob
are now begging him not to show i have
sources telling me tonight that his team
is saying well can we bring notes
now they clearly believe that joe biden
is too weak and too feeble
you're worried that he will be destroyed
by president trump
and fake conspiracy news theorists
cnn's own humpty dumpty tweeting that
this story
is far removed from reality oh okay
there's no violence
uh in seattle or portland and it's just
a summer of
love and festive atmosphere i guess they
forgot about their own network's
coverage or maybe
they're just psychotic liars over there
one top political analyst fake news cnn
actually pleading with
biden please don't don't debate donald
trump
here's a new york times op-ed entitled
let's scrap the presidential debates
here's another one from the boston
herald biden better walk
back and he offers to debate president
trump a report from newsweek claiming
that joe biden's own supporters were
urging him don't debate
the president now normally a candidate
challenging an incumbent pushes for as
many debates as possible
not joe biden and not his supporters
they want him to stay hiding
and for good reason his most recent
debate performances were well frankly
painful to watch so tonight we're going
to take you on
what is really a cringe-worthy trip down
memory lane because
you are the ultimate voter you will be
the jury
and the ultimate deciders in just 91
days
as we show you the very worst moments
now we start with this bizarre sound
bite of biden talking about
well clipping coupons in the stock
market
okay let's watch why in god's name
should someone who's clipping coupons in
the stock market
make in fact pay a lower tax rate than
someone who in fact is
like i said a school teacher and a
firefighter
uh does joe even know what he's trying
to say
another odd moment biden encouraging all
children to listen to a record player at
night when
we last had a record player take a look
play the radio make sure the television
excuse me
make sure you have the record player on
at night the
the phone make sure the kids hear words
and the confusion doesn't stop there one
debate he actually forgot that senator
kamala harris
even existed take a look i have more
people supporting me
in the black community than announced
for me because they know me they know
who i am
three former chairs of the black caucus
the only
african-american woman that ever been
elected to the united states senate
a whole range of people my point is true
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what day is it super thursday what state
am i in
no hard feeling senator joe can't even
seem to remember his own web address
or how text messaging works take a look
we have never never never been unable to
overcome whatever the problem was
if you agree with me go to joe
303 3 0
and help me in this fight by the way for
the record
that meant nothing there was no joe 303
30 anything
now confusion is not biden's only issue
well
he has fits of rage they're also
concerning for example here's a clip of
joe berating
his potential running mate elizabeth
warren let's take a look at that
let me she's referenced me i agreed with
the great job she did and i went on the
floor and got
you votes i got votes for that bill
i convinced people to vote for it so
let's get those things straight too
if you thought that was bad just listen
to his plan to eradicate
domestic violence no
man has a right to raise a hand to a
woman
in anger other than in self-defense and
that's
rarely ever occurs and so we have to
just change the culture
period and keep punching at it and
punching at it
and punching it it will be a big pro no
i really mean it
it make it's a gigantic issue
all right no one knows what's going to
come out of joe's mouth i don't even
think joe himself knows but what scares
democrats the most
are joe biden's well let's say weird
strange bizarre stories
here's one example take a look and by
the way you know i sit on the stand
and i get hot i got a lot of i got hairy
legs that turned
that that that that that that turn uh
um blonde in the sun and the kids used
to come up and reach into the pool
and rub my leg down so it was straight
and then watch the hair
come back up again they look at it so i
learned about roaches i learned about
kids jumping on my lap
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap
hairy legs turned blonde and kids like
to rub it
what leg hair children roaches what ask
yourself
this is a fair question does he have the
mental alertness
is this man fit to serve as the
commander-in-chief
does he have the strength and stamina
it's the most demanding job in the world
and it's obvious frankly to everyone
that joe biden is a
massive liability to himself to the
democratic party
and more importantly to this country as
a whole
and some on the left the radical left
they see it as an opportunity why
because he's like the dumb useful idiot
that
they will use to quote transform this
country and the economies he said
that's why this is by far the most
consequential election in our lifetime i
have a new book out today thank you you
made it number one on amazon.com
of the entire country live free or die
america in the world on the brink
it's out today hannity.com amazon.com
but in this book the reason i wrote this
first in 10 years
i cover in detail what makes this
country so special
and as reagan said and warned us freedom
is but
one generation away from extinction make
no mistake if the radical left
take over this country if they implement
their stated
socialist policies you can pretty much
kiss freedom goodbye and none of those
promises will ever be fulfilled
how's social security how's medicare
let's see how's that obamacare
keep your plan and your doctor and save
money how's that working out
how's it working out with safety and
security in cities run by liberal
democrats and states run by liberal
democrats for decades
how is the issue of education in those
cities come november 91 days
our future as a country and frankly the
world as goes america so
go so goes the world will be hanging in
the balance
you decide 91 days